bom o que nós vamos conversar hoje nós
vamos conversar sobre um tema
extremamente polêmico controverso o
transtorno de déficit de atenção e
hiperatividade e aqui vocês podem ver os
meus potenciais conflitos de interesse
ao abordar esse tema mas nós vamos
conversar sobre transtorno de déficit de
atenção e hiperatividade sobre mitos
relacionados ao transtorno
nada melhor do que começar conversando
sobre alguns mitos mais gerais da
neurociência ou que o the guardian
chamou grande mito no cérebro é aquele
que nos diz que nós usamos apenas 10% da
nossa capacidade cerebral
não existe nenhuma pesquisa bem
desenhada metodologicamente que tenha
conseguido mostrar esse número mágico de
10% de uso do cérebro
mesmo assim surpreendente mente
quase a metade dos professores na
inglaterra
mais da metade 68% dos professores nos
estados unidos e um terço dos alunos de
psicologia acredita nesse mito porque
gente porque o mito quando ele está vivo
poderia funcionante e tem um alto
impacto dentro da vida das pessoas então
não é surpresa e por exemplo existe uma
quantidade de remédios sendo propósito
sem nenhuma evidência científica para
aumentar o funcionamento cerebral ou
técnicas mirabolantes para aumentar a
capacidade de funcionamento do cérebro
é importante também levar em conta a
questão do mito é muito dependente do
tempo do momento histórico
ou seja aquilo que é uma verdade baseada
em evidência hoje pode ser um mito
amanhã e vice versa mas já que o nosso
assunto é o tal do transtorno de déficit
de atenção e hiperatividade apelidado aí
na web tdh
eu vou conversar com vocês sobre quatro
a afirmativas tidas por mim unidos que
circulam pela mídia ou pelos quatro
cantos da web
qual é o primeiro ministro o tph
transtorno deve ter atenção não existe
gente compreensão moderna das doenças
sejam quais forem indicam nós temos dois
tipos de doenças
aquelas que são categóricas uma infecção
bacteriana outro tenista bactéria ou não
pense que se comporta com a gravidez que
não é uma doença
não existe meia gravidez ou a mulher
está grávida ou não tá grave acontece e
boa parte das condições médicas têm
comportamento diferente comportamento
dimensional
isso vale para diabetes vale para
hipertensão pra hipercolesterolemia
então o que acontece
nós temos uma distribuição traço a uma
distribuição por exemplo hipertensão tá
pressão arterial na população em geral
nós temos um grupo que tem níveis
extremos o traço da hipertensão de
deveres extremos de pressão arterial e
se isso está associado à prejuízo ou
desfecho negativo na vida do indivíduo
nós temos uma doença
nós definimos isso uma doença atenção à
hiperatividade e impulsividade tem esse
comportamento dimensional da população
aliás a perspectiva mais moderna em
termos de transtornos mentais indica
claramente que ele se comporta
dimensionalmente o mais interessante
disso é que quando tu avalia
nesse lado direito aqui existe um
trabalho do instituto nacional de saúde
mental dos estados unidos que é um órgão
sem qualquer vinculação com a indústria
farmacêutica que mostrou o
desenvolvimento cerebral nas áreas que
comando o controle e inibitória freio
inibitório da pessoa o controle da
tensão esse desenvolvimento ele acontece
independente de o desenvolvimento
dimensional dos sintomas e da atenção e
hiperatividade ou seja aquelas áreas que
veiculam o controle inibitório eles se
desenvolvem dimensionalmente de acordo o
número de sintomas de delegar nos
mostramos um outro estudo há uma
característica cognitiva
associado a esse controle inibitório que
se chama processamento básico cerebral
nas regiões que estão associadas a esse
controle inibitório elas também têm um
comportamento dimensional relacionada à
aos sintomas a atenção e hiperatividade
impulsividade
então esse sintoma se distribuem
dimensionalmente e os mecanismos
neurobiológicos também tem uma
distribuição que é dimensional
agora é pra que a gente possa ver quem
está no extremo esse traço apresenta uma
doença é importante que a gente possa
caracterizar e está no extremo esse
traço de atenção e hiperatividade
impulsividade tem algum prejuízo e aí as
pesquisas são claras
elas indicam que a quem tem ph tem na
infância maiores chances de acidentes
domésticos na adolescência maior chance
de gravidez indesejadas maior chance de
aprovação e retenção escolar em adultos
maior chance de acidentes
automobilísticos eu quero compartilhar
com vocês um artigo saiu numa revista
se chama balança é uma das melhores
revistas médicas às 23 meses atrás e um
estudo baseado a dinamarquesa vocês
sabem que a dinamarca é muito cautelosa
em relação ao país em relação ao
diagnóstico psiquiátrico
nesse estudo baseado nos registros
médicos fui claramente demonstrado que
crianças adolescentes e adultos com
transtorno de déficit de atenção e uma
mortalidade maior do que quem não tem
transtorno de atenção e porque por
causas não naturais principalmente por
acidentes
então na minha opinião essa discussão e
debate que pegaram existe
ele está fora de foco eu acredito que
mesmo as pessoas mais contrárias ao
diagnóstico reconhecem que existe um
extremo da população em relação a esses
traços que esse extremo está associado à
prejuízo
a grande questão é a banalização da onde
coloca o ponto de corte
isto é que tem que ser melhor discutido
um outro mito é de que dh é apenas o
produto é o produto da civilização
ocidental principal principalmente da
civilização norte americana e priva ou
hã hã hãe uma necessidade ou preocupação
excessiva com o desempenho
se vocês olharem novamente a compreensão
moderna das doenças
a gente sabe que é uma doença era
determinada por uma vulnerabilidade
biológica associada à desencadeadores
ambientais
assim por exemplo se eu tenho dependendo
da minha vida e habilidade para gastrite
e dependendo do grau de stress no
ambiente eu vou apresentar ou não
gastrite a mesma coisa acontece
o transtorno de déficit de atenção e
hiperatividade e depende sim das
demandas ambientais e é claro que uma
sociedade cada vez exige mais em termos
de foco planejamento capacidade de
execução vai colocar uma pressão maior
dos indivíduos que têm estas
dificuldades
agora há uma variação da prevalência de
transtorno de déficit de atenção e
hiperatividade
nós realizamos um trabalho esse é o
trabalho é o quinto trabalho mais cidade
toda a história de transtorno de déficit
de atenção e hiperatividade
o trabalho que nós realizamos ouvia tá
falando junto com o professor da harvard
onde ela está agora
e nesse trabalho nós revisamos mais sem
estudos sobre transtorno de déficit de
atenção e hiperatividade espalhados em
diversos países de todos os continentes
mais de 170 mil indivíduos o que nós
mostramos aqui que a prevalência de pvh
ao redor do mundo andava ao redor de 5%
mas mais importante que isso as
variações nas prevalências na freqüência
transtornos de atenção e hiperatividade
entre os países
desaparece quando controla as diferenças
metodológicas entre os estudos o que
quis nos indica se as prevalências são
similares e culturas e sociedades
diferentes
é provável que a gente tenha um elemento
epe o lógico esteja subjacente a este
transtorno
então não há variação a de acordo com a
cultura ou a sociedade
o mais recente mito e circula pela web é
de que estamos vivendo uma epidemia de
transtorno de déficit de atenção e
hiperatividade basta você acessar em
qualquer uma das mídias e vocês vão
encontrar a esse tipo de chamar
claramente a isso de novo é uma
discussão é desfocada porquê porque no
mar
o aumento da frequência de bh nós
realizamos um outro estudo este estudo
avaliou 150
dois trabalhos ou prevalência do
transtorno de déficit de atenção e
hiperatividade
nas últimos 30 anos o que nós mostramos
claramente vocês podem ver isso aqui é
que ao longo das 13 três décadas a
prevalência então todos aponta um estudo
há e nós vemos que a prevalência média
ao longo das três décadas não muda ela é
completamente estável
então não há aumento da prevalência na
população mas isso não quer dizer que
não há aumento de diagnósticos para os
trabalhos mostram que há um aumento do
diagnóstico de transtorno de déficit de
atenção e serviços de saúde e é a gente
sabe que se aumente diagnóstico não é
não chega a um diagnóstico que todo
mundo que tem a condição só 20% dos
casos no brasil são diagnosticados
se eu colocar isso num cenário a mais
claro para vocês há como imaginar uma
cidade 1 100 mil habitantes
aonde se a 5% a prevalência nós temos 5
mil indivíduos um transtorno de déficit
de atenção e hiperatividade em 2000 se
identificava 100 indivíduos
voltamos em 2014 nessa cidade supondo
que a densidade demográfica se mantenha
e estão lá os 5 mil indivíduos
só que agora nós identificamos mil
indivíduos
então isso que vocês vêem na mídia nós
tivemos um aumento de dez vezes o
diagnóstico só que esse aumento
representa 20% dos casos reais e o que
determina esse aumento de diagnósticos
aqueles que são fanáticos pelo jec nós
tico e psicologia tinha teria dizem que
isto se deve a um maior reconhecimento
principalmente em mulheres e em em
adultos aqueles que são contrários ao
diagnóstico dizem que isso se deve à
pressão da indústria farmacêutica para
vender remédio provavelmente as duas
coisas estejam presentes somadas
a clara impressão também da sociedade
por desempenho por foco na execução que
faz com que haja uma mudança na
percepção dos nossos sonhos nossas
famílias dos nossos professores os
câmbio não aceitando pequenas diferenças
pelo menos poder ânsia e buscando uma
pressão maior
esse conjunto leva provavelmente a esse
aumento é de diagnósticos um outro a
admito que eu gostaria de discutir com
vocês é assim não há marcador biológico
bloco o tph não tem nenhuma base
biológica
se vocês olharem as pesquisas de
neuroimagens centenas de indivíduos com
th e centenas de indivíduos sem o
transtorno ou de genética com milhares
de indivíduos com tvh milhares de 25 e
bh
elas nos mostram claramente que existe
uma uma alteração de estrutura e
funcionamento cerebral e algumas
alterações genéticas
o problema é que pesquisa lida com um
grupo de indivíduos não lida o indivíduo
isolado
então o que acontece é que o cdh que nós
estamos vendo ele tem ele é muito
heterogêneo os sintomas de desatenção
hiperatividade impulsividade tem esse
caráter dimensional muito provavelmente
alguns grupos de gente vão ser
responsáveis por uma constelação de
sintomas ou por um ou mais dos
mecanismos biológicos associados à sua
gente tá exato
nesse artigo publicado semana passada
que nós participamos que visa toda esta
parte mas o que eu quero chamar a
atenção de vocês é que na verdade o que
acontece nós não temos marcador
biológico porque o marcador biológico
ele é facilmente demonstrado com
condições a onde nós temos clara a
diferença entre quem não tem a doença
pensa só que o ph com muitas das doenças
médicas pela heterogeneidade para
dimensionalidade alguns casos que não
tenha doença se comportam como tendo
algumas características da doença e
outros casos que têm a doença se
comporta como tendo a não tendo a doença
isto faz com que a busca de marcadores
biológicos é o nosso próximo passo da
pesquisa é mostrar o traduzir esse
conhecimento que a gente tem de grupo
para o indivíduo possa acontecer mas
isso tem que ser feito de uma forma
muito cuidadosa para não aumentar os
falsos positivos ou seja o alarme
desnecessário e os com os falsos
negativos não têm conhecimento da doença
agora é importante que a gente tenha
claro que o idh é o fato de não existir
um marcador biológico não quer dizer que
o delegado não exista não têm uma base
biológica porque senão não existiria
transtorno mental
não há marcador biológico para
esquizofrenia para autismo pra
transtorno de humor bipolar e ninguém
questiona a depressão ninguém questiona
a existência dessas doenças por sua base
biológica porque o preconceito com ph é
o meu convite é de que nós estamos mais
do que na hora de abandonar discussões
emocionais sobre fatos que nós temos uma
evidência científica claro que a gente
possa evoluir e bateu o que realmente
interessa nessa área
quais são os fatos quais são os fatos
científicos as evidências que nós temos
sobre o transtorno deve ter atenção em
primeiro lugar que dh existe e sempre
existiu ele representa o extremo de um
contínuo os traços de atenção e
hiperatividade impulsividade da
população e os indivíduos nesse extremo
tem
sim prejuízo funcional e as famílias
também são afetadas ea sociedade como um
todo
o th não é exclusivo de nenhuma
sociedade a ele está presente em todas
as sociedades e não há uma epidemia de
da população de diagnósticos ao maior
conhecimento e claramente o transtorno
de déficit de atenção e hiperatividade
tem uma base é biológico que nós temos
que discutir a onde botar o ponto de 4 a
partir de quando nós vamos intervir
isso depende de uma discussão
equilibrada entre os profissionais de
saúde sem conflito de interesse
mas também sem preconceitos arraigados
para que a gente possa determinar a onde
está o ponto de corte e dividir aqueles
indivíduos que baseado nesse traços
estão numa situação de risco
só assim a sociedade vai poder realmente
acolher os indivíduos um transtorno de
déficit de atenção e hiperatividade sim
estigmatizá los sem marginalizá-los
reconhecendo as suas dificuldades suas
áreas deficitárias
mas também as suas potencialidades
só assim gente nós vamos evoluir para
uma situação é que não aconteça a a a
passar isso não aconteça o que aconteceu
a recentemente do estados unidos uma
escola estados unidos aonde o menino o
ph foi algemado em função da agitação
esse é o nosso grande desafio o desafio
certamente vai exigir mais do que 10% da
nossa capacidade cerebral muito obrigado
pela atenção